Gisele Bundchen speaks out about her
split from Tom Brady and responds to
claims she gave him an ultimatum I feel
like I'm so driven to succeed in
football and that's taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family
Bill covers the latest issue of Vanity
Fair and inside the bag she opens up for
the first time about the divorce which
was announced in October 2022 calling it
The Death of her dream before slamming
claims that she told Tom he had to
choose between their marriage and
football what's been said is one piece
of a much bigger puzzle it's not so
black and white Giselle calls the claims
very hurtful and the craziest things
she's ever heard and adds that she's
always cheered for him and if there's
one person she wants to be happy it's
him I want him to achieve and to conquer
I want all his dreams to come true
that's what I want really from the
bottom of my heart as for what led to
their divorce the supermodel says they
simply grew apart and wanted different
things Giselle notes that she was 26 and
he was 29 when they first met she's now
42. he's 45. I think the best is still
yet to come
Giselle adds that there is lots of love
but in order to be authentic you have to
have someone who can meet you in the
middle when you love someone you don't
put them in a jail and say you have to
live this life you set them free to be
who they are and if they want to fly the
same direction then that's amazing she's
my best friend we spend as much time as
we can together and you know it's a busy
life we have and you know with three
kids it's busy schedules busy for me Tom
and Gisele were first linked in 2007 and
tied the knot in 2009 they share two
children a 13 year old son Benjamin and
a 10 year old daughter Vivian Tom also
has a 15 year old son jack with his ex
Bridget Moynihan you get to see him
develop and you see these different
parts of their life and they teach you
so much I mean the kids are so wonderful
and moving forward Giselle says they're
still a team I look back and I have no
regrets I loved every bit of it it's a
sentiment that was echoed in October
when they first announced their split on
Instagram and while Gisele waited months
to speak out about life after divorce
Tom opened up a few days after their
initial announcement when he was still
the quarterback of the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers prior to retirement the good
news is things it's a very amicable
situation and I'm really focused on two
things and taking care of my family
and certainly my children and secondly
doing the best job I can to win football
games so that's what professionals do
you focus at work when it's time to work
and then when you come home you focus on
the priorities that are at home and all
you can do is the best you could do
[Music]
thank you